>> Tucker: IN EARLY FEBRUARY
OF THIS YEAR A GROUP OF
LAWMAKERS IN SOUTH DAKOTA
TRIED TO PASS A BILL TO BAN
RADICAL MEDICAL
EXPERIMENTATION ON YOUNG
CHILDREN.
UNDER HEAVY PRESSURE FROM
BUSINESS GROUPS LIKE THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
REPUBLICAN DOMINATED
LEGISLATURE VOTED IT DOWN
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
WELL, AS YOU PROBABLY
GUESSED BY NOW BECAUSE
CONDUCTING RADICAL MEDICAL
EXPERIMENTS ON CHILDREN IS
NOW POPULAR.
THESE EXPERIMENTS ARE JUFD
IN THE NAME OF
TRANSGENDERRISM.
THE FAILED SOUTH DAKOTA BILL
WOULD HAVE BARRED DOCTORS
FROM PERFORMING SEX
REASSIGNMENT SURGERY ON
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
16.
NOW THESE ARE RADICAL OFTEN
IRREVERSIBLE PROCEDURES THAT
CAN INCLUDE DOUBLE
MASTECTOMIES, STERILIZATION
AND CASTRATION.
THE BILL WOULD HAVE ALSO
BARRED DOCTORS FROM
PRESCRIBING HORMONES TO AID
IN THE TRANSITION PROCESS.
ONCE AGAIN ONLY FOR THOSE
UNDER 16.
NOW, IT WOULD YOU SAY USED
TO BE THAT EVERYONE AGREED
WITH THIS IDEA.
IT WAS COMMON SENSE.
ADULTS ARE FREE TO DO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THEY WANT.
BUT IF YOU ARE 15 OR 9 OR
10, YOU ARE TOO YOUNG TO
CONSENT TO PROFOUND ACTS.
TOO YOUNG TO CONSENT TO SEX
AND TOO YOUNG TO HAVE YOUR
SEX ORGANS CUT OFF.
IT’S SIMPLE.
IT’S BEEN A OPERATING
UNDERSTANDING IN THE WEST
FOR A THOUSAND YEARS.
THE RETICENCE TO MUTILATE
CHILDREN ONCE NOW MORALLY
OBVIOUS IS NOW SEEN AS
BIGOTED AS THE TRANSGENDER
MOVEMENT ACTIVISTS PUSHED TO
TRANSITION CHILDREN AS
YOUNGER AND YOUNGER AGES.
IT HAS BECOME COMMON TO
PLACE CHILDREN ON DRUGS DRUGS
WHICH SUPPRESS HORMONE
THEREBY BLOCK THE ONSET OF
PUBERTY.
ONE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
HAS ENDORSED PROVIDING THESE
DRUGS PUBERTY BLOCKERS AT
TAXPAYER EXPENSE.
ARE PUBERTY DRUGS SAFE?
AND THE ANSWER IS WE HAVE NO
IDEA IF THEY ARE SAFE.
IT WAS INITIALLY DEVELOPED
TO ADVANCE PROSTATE CANCER
IN ELDERLY MAN SEVERE OR
LONG-TERM SIDE EFFECTS WERE
NOT MUCH OF A TURNER
CONCERN.
THE DRUG HAS BEEN USED TO
TREAT PRECOCIOUS PUBERTY
CHILDREN UNDER 5 UNDERGO
PREHORMONAL CHANGES.
WHAT’S THE RESULT OF
BLOCKING ON CHILDREN NO
MEDICAL CAUSE TO DO SO?
WE DON’T KNOW THE ANSWER.
ACTIVISTS CLAIM THE DRUGS
ARE FULLY REVERSIBLE BUT WE
DON’T KNOW THAT THAT’S TRUE.
BESIDES DELAYING PHYSICAL
MATURITY, LUPRON EFFECTS
BONE DENSITY.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS,
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
ADULTS WHO TOOK IT AS
CHILDREN AND NOW HAVE TO
BATTLE WITH BONE AND JOINT
PROBLEMS MORE COMMON IN THE
ELDERLY.
FEW SMALL STUDIES INDICATE
WHEN USED TO ARREST PUSHED
LUPRON CAN LOWER IQ
COGNITIVE ABILITY BY 7 TO
THE POINTS WHICH IS A LOT.
THAT IS REALLY THE CASE IT
WOULDN’T BE SURPRISING SINCE
PUBERTY IS CRUCIAL TO
COMPLETING THE BRAIN’S
DEVELOPMENT.
SPEAKING OF THE BRAIN, THE
RUSH TO PLACE CHILDREN ON
PUBERTY BLOCKERS IS
JUSTIFIED ON THE GROUNDS OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL HEALTH.
GENDER DYSPHORIC KIDS WHO
CAN’T GO ON HORMONES RIGHT
AWAY WE ARE TOLD WILL LIKELY
BECOME DEPRESSED OR
SUICIDAL.
OKAY.
IT TURNS OUT THE DEPRESSION
IS IN FACT A KNOWN SIDE
EFFECT OF PUBERTY BLOCKERS
IRONY OF IRONY.
AFTER A YEAR ON PUBERTY
BLOCKERS CHILDREN WERE
DRAMATICALLY MORE LIKELY
WITH THE STATEMENT I
DELIBERATELY TRY TO HURT OR
KILL MYSELF WHILE THEY WERE
TAKING THE DRUG.
SO FAR THERE IS ZERO
LONG-TERM STUDIES LOOKING AT
THE PHYSICAL OR MENTAL
EFFECT OF HEALTHY CHILDREN
GOING ON PUBERTY BLOCKERS
WHETHER THEY LATER GO
THROUGH A FULL SEX CHANGE OR
NOT.
SIMILARLY WE KNOW ALMOST
NOTHING ABOUT THE LONG-TERM
PROGNOSIS OF CHILDREN WHO
UNDERGO FULL PHYSICAL
TRANSITION.
IT’S SIMPLY TOO KNEW.
WE DON’T KNOW.
WE DO HAVE STUDIES THOUGH ON
WHAT HAPPENED TO GENDER
DISFORK CHILDREN WHO DON’T
RECEIVE PUBERTY BLOCKERS.
IN ABOUT 80% OF THOSE CASES,
BOYS WHO WISH THEY WERE
GIRLS OR GIRLS WHO WISH THEY
WERE BOYS EVENTUALLY GET
OVER IT AND TURN OUT FIND
WITH NO RADICAL.
MANY OF THESE ADULTS BECOME
GAY OR BY SEXUAL BUT STILL
IDENTIFY WITH BIOLOGICAL SEX
AND THEY DO NOT WANT SEX
CHANGE SURGERY.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THAT MEANS THAT MOST, IF NOT
ALL CHILDREN WITH GENDER
DYSPHORIA SHOULD WAIT UNTIL
ADULTHOOD TO TRANSITION,
OTHERWISE, THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THEM WILL GET EXPENSIVE,
INVASIVE, POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS POSSIBLY
IRREVERSIBLE TREATMENT THEY
NEVER NEEDED AND IN THE END
WOULDN’T HAVE WANTED ANYWAY.
BUT ACTIVISTS CAN’T WAIT FOR
ADULTHOOD.
THEY WANT ANY CHILDREN WITH
GENDER DYSPHORIA TO BE
PUSHED INTO A FULL
TRANSITION AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WANT
DOCTORS TO CARRY OUT A VAST
HUMAN EXPERIMENT WITH THIS
NATION’S CHILDREN, YOUR
CHILDREN SUBJECTS.
AND IT REALLY IS A VAST
EXPERIMENT.
IN 2009, THE U.K.’S GENDER
IDENTIFIED AT THIS
DEVELOPMENT SERVICE OR GIDS
RECEIVED 77 REFERRALS FOR
CHILD GENDER DISFOR I CAN’T.
A DECADE LATER, THEY
RECEIVED ALMOST 2,600:
INCREASE OF MORE THAN
3,000%.
NOTABLY, WHILE A DECADE AGO
MOST DYSPHORIC CHILDREN WERE
BIOLOGICALLY MALE TODAY
BIOLOGICALLY FEMALE.
WHY IS THAT?
SEEMS LIKE FINDING OUT.
DESPITE THE RISK, SOME HAVE
TRIED TO DO.
SO IN 2018, BROWN UNIVERSITY
RESEARCHER LISA LITTMAN
FOUND MANY TEENAGE GIRLS ARE
ABRUPTLY IDENTIFYING AS
TRANSGENDER AS SEEING A
FRIEND DO SO OFFER ARE A
BEING EXPOSED TO
PRO-TRANSMATERIAL ONLINE AND
5U68 LOT OF THAT
IMPRESSIONABLE TEEN GIRLS
MAY LITERALLY BE TAKING PART
IN A FAD THAT INVOLVES
IRREVERSIBLE SURGERY AT THE
END OF IT.
HERE IS A TERRIFYING QUOTE
FROM THE TIMES OF LONDON A
MAINSTREAM BRITISH NEWSPAPER
AND WE’RE QUOTING HERE.
3 5G ID CLINICIANS HAVE
RESIGNED IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS MANY ALARMED BY THE
RUSH TO MEDICALIZATION AND
THE WAY INSTAGRAM
TRANSINFLUENCERS AND THE
CBBC PROGRAM I AM LEO
PRESENT TRANSITION AS
UNCOMPLICATED.
THEY ARE SEEING GIRLS WITH A
PANOPLY OF OTHER ISSUES,
ANXIETY, DEPRESSION,
SELF-HARM, UNDIAGNOSED
AUTISM THAT COMES WITH
HOMOPHOBIC BULLYING AND
SEXUAL ABUSE FOR WHOM
TRANSITION TO MALE BODY
ONLINE AS UNIVERSAL PAN SEE
A OFTEN A NORMAL TOM-BOYISH
DISGUST AT THEIR NEW BREAST
ELICITING SUDDEN AND
UNWANTED SEXUAL ATTENTION
FROM MEMBER IS UNTURNER IS I
THAT THEY ARE IN THE WRONG
BODY.
INSTEAD OF ININTERROGATING
THESE UNDERLYING ISSUES.
CLINICIANS ARE TOLD TO
AFFIRM A YOUNG PERSON’S
TRANSIDENTITY AND PUBERTY
BLOCK HEIERSINSIST ARE THEIR RIG
UNQUOTE.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THAT’S HORRIFYING.
IT’S NOT MEDICINE.
IT’S SOMETHING ELSE.
AT THIS MOMENT 19 U.S.
STATES BAN SO-CALLED
CONVERSION THERAPY FOR
MINORS.
THAT’S A THERAPY THAT CLAIMS
IT’S POSSIBLE FOR GAY PEOPLE
TO BECOME HETEROSEXUAL.
STATES HAVE BANNED IT EVEN
THOUGH IT INVOLVES NO
SURGERY OR MEDICATION OR
PHYSICAL TREATMENT ON THE
GROUNDS THAT IT DOESN’T WORK
AND IT COULD DRIVE GAY
TEENAGERS INTO DEPRESSION OR
SUICIDE.
IN EFFECT, AND THIS IS THE
KEY, THOSE STATES HAVE SAID
THAT IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE
A RISKY ELECTIVE THERAPY
WITH NO PROOF IT WILL WORK,
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL A
CHILD HAS BECOME AN ADULT.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
SIMILARLY MANY STATES BAN
MINORS FOR GETTING TATTOOS
FOR THE SAME REASON.
THEY ARE PERMANENT AND
CHANGE YOUR LIFE FOREVER.
KIDS OUGHT TO WAIT UNTIL
ADULTHOOD UNTIL THEY MAKE
THAT CHOICE.
THIS USED TO BE OBVIOUS,
ONCE AGAIN.
BUT ON THE FAR MORE RADICAL
TREATMENTS USED FOR
TRANSGENDERRISM, STATES ARE
DOING NOTHING AT ALL.
SOUTH DAKOTA LAWMAKERS HAVE
THE CHANCE TO SAY NO.
AND SPARED THEIR CHILDREN
FROM THIS INSANITY.
BUT THEY DECLINED TO DO IT.
WHY?
WELL, THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ATTACKED THE BILL.
THEY SAID IT THREATENED THE
STATE’S ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND APPARENTLY REPUBLICANS
IN SOUTH DAKOTA AGREED.
SHAMEFULLY.
BY THE WAY IT REALLY WAS
REPUBLICANS WHO DID THIS.
THE SOUTH DAKOTA HOUSE HAS
59 REPUBLICANS AND JUST 11
DEMOCRATS.
THE SENATE IS 30 REPUBLICANS
TO FIVE DEMOCRATS.
AND, YET, A BILL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM MEDICAL
EXPERIMENTATION STILL
COULDN’T GET THROUGH THE
STATE HOUSE.
REMEMBER THE REPUBLICAN ALSO
DO ALMOST ANYTHING TO
PROTECT BUSINESSES ACCESS TO
CHEAP LABOR.
BUT YOUR CHILDREN PROTECTING
YOUR CHILDREN?